[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i should be talking more basketball but
chris sims pro football talk live
co-host is uh got his quarterback list
and i'm always fascinated
with this because sims is not afraid
he'll put out this list top 40
quarterbacks
and he's down to his top five uh
actually down to his top four because
i'm looking at the list here
russell wilson is five lamar jackson six
kyla murray seven
matthew stafford eight dak prescott nine
tom brady is
ten let's bring in chris sims from pro
football talk live
all right give me the criteria for how
you set up the rankings chris
sure i i got a you know 40 quarterbacks
it's basically my depth chart
uh dan that that's how i do it
everybody's playing on the same team
we're not taking the advantages of oh
this guy has
this or this coach or whatever you know
it's the same team
it's the same coaches and here's my
depth chart 1 through 40
going into the 20 20 21 season
all right we have some we have some
questions here
sure uh who wants to start paulie i'll
let you start with sims
uh i don't know how obvious i want to go
here i i guess i'll go obviously
so i have a better chance to win with
matthew stafford as my quarterback then
tom brady as my quarterback
well yeah i do believe that listen brady
hey leadership you know what he brought
to that team
it's really special and i took that all
into account in fact i bumped him up in
front of people where i would go they're
more talented they can do more on the
field
than he can but for that scenario and
what he did with tampa he was the
perfect fit
they needed polish down there and all
those type of things
yes okay but at the same time there's a
lot of
issues and like tom brady's game is not
perfect you know and matthew stafford
don't get so blinded by
you know detroit lions and their record
and everything like that that's the only
thing i would argue with you there is i
mean who did you think detroit was
supposed to beat last year
what on their roster was really that
special that you think matt stafford was
supposed to look so great and do all
those type of things
you know i can look at tampa bay and go
hey they lost five losses in the regular
season
you can legitimately look at all five
and go the
main culprit in all five losses was tom
brady
let alone the nfc championship game and
those issues too so brady's awesome his
arm is still
awesome he makes very few plays off of
schedule
he needs a certain type of support
system around him right now
as to where i look at some of these
other guys and go they don't need it
and they can still make things happen
and go that way it's a tough one
and i i know that's the one that
everybody looks at and nobody's happy
unless i make brady one or two
that's the only thing i can make happy
make everybody happy no i wouldn't put
him there
yeah but i but i would i would put him
ahead yeah you put him ahead of those
guys yeah
i would sure you don't like jared goff
at all
man you got well you got him 31 you got
three rookies ahead of him
you got jameis winston you got taysom
hill ahead of james
yeah you know jared goff you know tell
me what am i signing up for
you know is it sean mcvay's offense i
don't know but i mean again with jared
goff there's experience
certainly but not the experience where i
would like
to see it to be for a guy that's played
as long as he has
and and been to the super bowl you know
there's just too many
plays when you watch it and reevaluate
where i go man
bad decision you know not understanding
the full scope of the game
hey it's a bootleg it's third and one
you know
nobody's open and go run for the first
down and he throws the ball away or like
tries to throw the ball into double
coverage
you know that that to me concerns me let
alone like not
great ability you know nothing he does
off schedule to help the football team
that way
not a top tier throw of the football and
you know
yeah so yes i look at it that way and
let's not forget dan
they were doing everything they could in
life to start john wolford at the end of
the year
they did not want to start jared goblins
that was because the play was not good
so
you know yeah that's that's where i
stand with with him right now all right
mclovin your question for sims
okay you have kyler murray in number
seven the cardinals quarterback if he's
the seventh best quarterback and he has
all these hall of famers everywhere on
this roster and all this town how come
nobody thinks the cardinals are gonna do
anything this year
they're generally considered the fourth
best team in that division
yeah i i agreed you know but it's not
all about the quarterback you know let's
let's let's stop that
stop you know mclovin i know you know he
makes them
considerably better in my opinion you
know they're one of the top rushing
offenses in football
not because their old line is great or
the running backs great it's because
kyler murray is unbelievable
scrambling the threat he has to run with
the quarterback design
run plays or the read options that opens
up everything
i'm not sure so sure he's not like the
most responsible out of like
all quarterbacks as far as improving
their offense or making it look a lot
better than it really is
you know their scheme itself is nothing
special
i break this down on my podcast all the
time if you know we do deandre hopkins
his route combinations
i mean it's it's limited it's a lot of
that spread four
wide it's a little predictable and he is
the reason
it goes so yeah we'll see can aj green
help them out you know we'll see if
larry fitzgerald plays and all those
things but he's a special special talent
uh that you know it's hard to always
quantify
his effect on the game or qualify it
uh you know through stats because of the
pressure he does put on your defense
because of his
his skill set yes todd you got a
question so chris you have drew lock at
33
a lot higher up on the board than i
thought so there's some positivity i
should have if you
can't get aaron rodgers there's hope for
denver to chase kansas city
drew locke has like fritzy some big time
top end talent like i excited about
the positives if we've sat all down
together and watched drew lock the
positives we'd all go
whoa whoa man you're right he is a
little better makes a little more
you know makes more plays than i thought
he does have an explosive arm he is a
pretty good athlete
the big thing as you know fritzy because
i know you're a broncos fan he's got to
take that like brett favre element out
of his game
not every throw has to be a 25-yard
laser in between four people to fit it
in there
that's enough that's enough that's
enough talk about the broncos okay
[Laughter]
uh you got ryan tannehill ahead of baker
mayfield uh ryan tannehill at number 12
baker mayfield do you like baker
mayfield or you just tolerate baker
mayfield
no i do like baker mayfield i do i to me
last year was a huge year for him like
showed progress
like maturity on and off the field and
the one thing that
just really popped to me was
how many high level high degree of
difficulty throws
baker mayfield made during the year
especially the second half of the year
you know he's got a great innate ability
to wear i don't call him a great
runner but he's a great mover you know
he hops around the pocket and he can
make throws kind of
from weird angles or he's got a bootleg
and the defense ends there to get him
and he kind of makes a move and breaks
his ankle and still gets the throw or
you know he's running full speed on a
bootleg and there's jarvis landry 25
field and he's opened by three inches
and then he rips it in there and doesn't
think twice and throws it perfectly
so it's an offense that's not
necessarily always quarterback friendly
with all these crazy things they do they
ask their quarterback to make
big time explosive throws and he fixed
his mechanics last year he played the
game better
and he made a number of big time plays
to to help their team win football games
we're talking to chris sims pro football
talk
live uh is number one on the list
going to be controversial
no no i i will say my top four as you
know i have not revealed that yet and
that will be monday and if
you guys want to have me back next week
to talk about or whatever
i do think there's gonna be one here in
the top four
that's gonna people are gonna go whoa
okay
so that's all i'll say to that to tease
it uh but
this is a it's a tough exercise as you
can imagine i'm just setting myself up
to get crapped on by everybody
uh and i deal with it every year uh but
but you know you ask for this chris i do
well an
nbc asks me to do it i don't ask i don't
go hey let's do it
but it's part of what i do and i do
enjoy it to a degree
it helps me get better feel for the
quarterbacks and and
you know kind of have that jump off
point for the next year and the other
thing you realize dan there's a lot of
damn good quarterbacks in football right
now
a lot of them there really is and it's
it's about the support system and
to see how good they're going to be you
got tuatanga vialoa 34th
yeah um there's only 32
teams so he's not good enough to start
in your opinion
well he's not one of the 32
best that the way i see it right now
yeah there's question marks
certainly i mean you saw last year
again it was good but they had to
micromanage him
you know and then whenever they had to
let it loose we got to take them out we
got to put ryan fitzpatrick in
he's admitted he didn't know the offense
as well he didn't make that many plays
with his right arm or anything like that
you know so yeah i have a lot of
questions you know and
it's that's the one that seems to be the
most polarizing people think i hate to
i root for him i like the guy he's
charismatic as hell
there's no doubt about it but yeah
there's nothing to write home about last
year to where i go
man that's special and i'm i'm he's
ready to jump into the top 20. i got to
see more
and to believe that so mahomes will be
one
um
uh you're funny aaron rodgers is two
i'm not telling you anything what about
what about his mindset
is he totally committed to playing
football here
i don't know you'll have to you know
what you'll have to do he he's in love
he wants to do jeopardy right i don't
know
where's his mind well maybe chris sims
took that into account
maybe you should watch my podcast on
monday and i'll explain all these
answers to you uh where is desean watson
he's not even on the board
well he's gonna be in those top four uh
he is he's coming up
yeah i mean i'm not avoiding him right
now i mean i know there's no way
you got deshawn watson one of the top
four quarterbacks in the nfl right now
yes i do uh yes without a doubt no doubt
yes he is a
superstar so josh allen's gonna be there
aaron rodgers patrick
you got the four that are last shot okay
yeah
watson probably had the best year of his
career last year now it didn't translate
to wins or losses
yeah i get that but i mean it's horrible
defense
no run game no receivers you know they
were highly competitive in a lot of
games where i'd go
man if they didn't have desean watson
this game would be 40 to 7
they would be getting killed and here
they were in the fourth quarter with a
chance to win or
you know somebody snaps the ball low
when he's on the one-yard line
you know he can't do everything so uh
that's that's part of the exercise
it is tough but yeah i look at watson as
certainly being one of the four best
quarterbacks in the league right now
i think you jumped on my matthew
stafford bandwagon mvp
choice well i think you did i
i i'm excited for stafford because
stafford has been in like my top ten
almost every year i do this and people
always just can't get over it and it's
you know again it's just man battle
bad offense no great offensive
coordinators his whole career
i know he had megatron it was him and
megatron apparently those two were
supposed to win every game by themselves
i get that
you know no thousand-yard rushers the
talon is real
it's one of the greatest arms ever it's
still one of the most game-changing arms
we've ever seen and still at this point
it is and i think this year
now with the support mcvay's offense
some receivers a run game
i hear you like that's to me the smart
bet if you want to bet
low and get a huge grand prize for mvp
matt stafford be one of those i would i
would recommend anybody
you got ben roethlisberger down the list
here should the steelers
have made should they have drafted a
quarterback
first round instead of a running back
yeah
it's it's tough um you know where they
were sitting there
of course that they would have had to
have made some sort of move
to get a quarterback and i think that's
why they did sign dwayne haskins in the
offseason to take it
you know let's take a deeper look at him
maybe he could be the guy of the future
but i think ultimately dan would like
pittsburgh they looked at it like
wait we're closer to the top than the
bottom this
some good available you can't ask ben to
throw the ball
you know every play 45 times a game and
then
not be able to run or scare anybody else
with that so they gotta go to that
formula in my opinion run the ball
play action protect him up so he doesn't
have to worry and he'll still dice you
up with his right arm
but he's not going to make plays or
carry the team anymore if they're going
to ask him to be in the shotgun and do
it that way all game long
it's good to talk to you again and
always and i hope you get a whole lot of
grief coming up next week
oh no don't worry i think it's you know
it's peaked
i honestly there's a crazy thing when i
made brady 10 i was like man
people will probably be happy about this
this is good let's get some people off
my back i think it's the worst reaction
i've gotten in the years out of anybody
i am getting absolutely killed wait what
was that
what's the worst reaction you you had
gotten prior to putting tom brady tenth
on your list
uh well i mean it's probably another tom
brady
you know ranking of like putting him at
nine a few years ago or something like
that
it's usually that between the new
england fans still upset
because you were there as a teammate of
tom brady's of tom
that's what everybody says i know i was
jealous
he was mean to me all those type of
things and i know nobody can believe
that i actually really like the guy and
have tremendous respect but yes that's
the way i see it at age 43
where he is right now he's still awesome
obviously can win a super bowl
but i don't think he's as good or better
than some of those guys i got in front
of him no i don't thank you chris
thank you dan be good guys see ya that's
uh chris sims pro football talk live
nbc sports take a break play the day up
next here on the dan patrick show